also menschen die sich wirklich und
aufrecht sorgen machen die sollten sehr
darauf achten mit wem sie sich da
gemeinsam auf die straße begeben sollten
auch selber massnahmen ergreifen dass
genau das nicht passieren kann dass es
nicht zu einer vermischung kommen kann
mit rechten reichs bürgern identitäten
kroner rebellen und dergleichen mehr das
ist auch etwas was diese menschen
leisten müssen und auch deutlich machen
auf unsere generation tragen wird die
maske wollte eigentlich dagegen sind
aber die maske pflicht ist sozusagen der
preis dafür der preis den wir bezahlen
müssen das ist zu einer gewissen
normalisierung in den schulen in
betrieben wieder kommen kann
angelique du warst für uns bei dieser
demonstration hast also auch miterlebt
wie die stimmung vor ort war man muss
sagen sie war tatsächlich sehr erhitzt
wie hast du das ganze dort erlebt hast
du die menschen erlebt also ich habe
eine sehr beängstigende stimmung gesehen
es gibt eine situation wir waren mitten
in einer live-schalte weil wir von den
demonstrationen berichtet haben und wir
haben nicht von außerhalb berichtet
sondern von der demonstration und wir
waren mittendrin während dieser live
schalte wurden wir umzingelt von
bestimmt 30 35 menschen die angefangen
haben zu uns an zu schreien die uns
wieder nach vorne noch nach hinten gehen
haben lassen die lügen presse
geschrieben haben die uns beleidigt
haben die versucht haben die kabel aus
der kamera zu ziehen
wir wurden mit wasser bespritzt etc also
ich fand es wirklich sehr beängstigend
weil in dieser situation waren wir wir
haben die man provoziert es ist nicht
mal so dass wir in dieser situation
leute gefragt hätten warum sind sie denn
auf der demonstration manchmal ist es
schon provokation genug wir waren
einfach nur in der menge
haben diese live schalte gemacht und das
war schon provokation genug um uns so
einzukesseln und das paradoxe ist ja
eigentlich die leute schreien nach
freiheit die leute schreien nach frieden
aber die pressefreiheit scheinen sie
dann nicht zu akzeptieren
einer der sätze in der live schalte die
auch gesagt dass du hast keine polizei
in diesem moment gesehen deswegen auch
die frage inwiefern war das konzept der
polizei von berlin
vielleicht fehlerhaft wir haben den
sturm auf den reichstag gesehen wirklich
erschreckende bilder wie konnte so was
überhaupt passieren dass man sowohl bei
der demo irgendwo sicherheitskräfte
gesehen hat und dann es tatsächlich zu
diesen dramatischen bildern kommen
konnte
man hat in der tat unterschätzt wie
ernsthaft das vorhaben einige rechte
gruppierungen ist auch wie machtvoll
diese strömungen auftreten kann
ich will die bewegung nicht größer
machen als sie wirklich ist das ernst zu
nehmen sollte auch nicht unterschätzt
werden nicht bagatellisiert werden aber
man sollte ja auch nicht mehr raum geben
als ihr zusteht das ist immerhin eine
kleine etwas bizarre minderheit die dort
auf die straße geht die mehrheit tickt
nicht so und deswegen ist es gerade
wichtig dass die mehrheit deutlich macht
wir wollen und schon abgrenzen vor
diesen manchmal etwas absurden und
abstrusen vorstellungen die manchmal
hier geäußert werden und wer für
grundrechte auf die straße geht muss wir
haben gerade eben gehört auch die
meinungs- und pressefreiheit
respektieren dass sich auch schon die
widersprüchlichkeit mancher teilnehmer
auf der einen seite für ihre grundrechte
zu streiten aber die rundliche der
presse die presse zu missachten und zu
attackieren was sollten jetzt die
konsequenzen daraus sein wenn das
nächste mal wieder eine solche demo in
berlin stattfinden soll jetzt im vorlauf
gab es ja erst das verbot das aufgehoben
worden ist war natürlich
versammlungsfreiheit ein wichtiges gut
ist welche konsequenz welchen maßnahmen
müsste man jetzt bei der nächsten
demonstration in berlin ziehen also ein
verbot ist ganz offensichtlich ein
falsches ungeeignetes und nicht
angemessenes instrument ist provoziert
sogar noch eher damit müssen wir umgehen
dass man trainieren kann ist ein
wichtiges grundrecht bei uns in
deutschland und dabei sollte es auch
bleiben also situation sollte man zu
lassen aber ganz ganz klare auflagen
auferlegen deutlich machen es muss eine
mengenbegrenzung geben das muss klar
sein was ist der bereich auf dem
demonstriert wird der bereich muss auch
irgendwie um verliebtsein und da dürfen
nur eine bestimmte anzahl von menschen
mit masken unter wahrung der
abstandsregeln diesen diesen raum
betreten so kann man die traktion
durchführen und zu lassen und sollte das
nicht eingehalten werden dann muss man
genau das tun was jetzt eben auch
gemacht und ziehen was versucht war das
in berlin
demonstrationen zu beenden und
aufzulösen da warst du dabei sie sollte
relativ früh aufgelöst werden man hat
aber trotzdem ein bisschen in späten
abend bilder gesehen von großen gruppen
wie hast du das wahrgenommen als dem
moment kam und die polizei gesagt hätte
wir lösen diese veranstaltung jetzt auf
gab es viele die dann wirklich gegangen
sind weil sie sich eben an die gesetze
halten und verstanden haben
jetzt geht sie nicht weiter auch wenn
sie natürlich das recht zu demonstrieren
haben oder dass der großteil geblieben
also es gab immer mal wieder situationen
man hat über lautsprecher dann gehört
zum beispiel am brandenburger tor
es wurde mehrfach darauf hingewiesen
dass man sich doch jetzt bitte an die
hygienemaßnahmen halten soll sonst wird
diese versammlung einfach aufgelöst
daran wurde sich nicht gehalten also ich
habe glaube ich kaum menschen gesehen
die dann tatsächlich nach links und nach
rechts gegangen sind und dann einfach
das gemacht haben was die polizei gesagt
hat eigentlich das gegenteil sie sind
geblieben
und um noch einmal auf dieses
gewaltpotenzial zu kommen es gibt ich
bin dann nach dieser demonstration nach
hause gegangen war total erschöpft von
dem was ich gesehen habe von diesem
gewaltpotenzial dieser vermeintlich
friedlichen demonstration
ich habe droh mails bekommen hush hush
nachrichten auf allen möglichen
plattformen die leider so schlimm sind
dass ich sie hier gar nicht vortragen
kann und das muss uns eigentlich schon
zu denken geben dass allein die
anwesenheit der presse schon zu solchen
provokationen führt weil viele der leute
und das kann man glaube ich schon so
sagen sind ab wie wir so ein bisschen
abgehängt ja dafür wie für die sind wir
fake news und da ist es egal ob man für
bild auf der straße ist und als reporter
auf der straße ist ob man für ard zdf
alle sind fake news sie orientieren sich
an alternativen fakten haben ihre
eigenen quellen und die nehmen sie für
bare münze und das ist gefährlich
eine abschließende frage wird corona
jetzt genutzt um eine art wikipedia
bewegung noch mal in slough zu bekommen
dass mehr menschen sich jetzt hinter
diesem vorwand der korona maßnahmen
zusammenrotten um eben gegen die
regierung jetzt der stimmung zu machen
im ganzen land die menschen dürfen der
recht mehr über auch nicht auf den leim
gehen müssen sich selber immunisieren
sozusagen im klaren sein das eine ist
die regierung wegen bestimmter maßnahmen
die vielleicht auch zu rigide gewesen
sind aber das kann man ja diskutieren zu
demonstrieren sich dagegen zu äußern
sich aber eben nicht vor den karren
spannen zu lassen für ganz andere
vorhaben ganz andere gruppen den tieren
und der reichs bürger das muss jetzt
gelingen das müssen auch diese menschen
schaffen dass das sie klammern was ist
der gegenstand ihres protestes nämlich
vielleicht zu strenge maßnahmen die
ihren beruf ihr familienleben so stark
beeinträchtigt aber gleichwohl muss uns
klar sind
viele menschen die angst haben vor
corona wenn wir in andere länder blicken
italien spanien muss uns klar sein das
ist nicht ein hirngespinst corona ist
real und wir müssen etwas dagegen tun
und was sie dagegen tun ist eben masken
pflicht und abstandsregeln und dabei
muss es bleiben